it seems like clubhouse is uh
you know on the downward path and it's
very possible to see
a billion plus dollar deal at some stage
maybe like a year ago or half a year ago
from facebook from google i think
facebook was flirting with that idea too
and
[Music]
i think a lot of companies probably were
i wish it was more public
you know what there's not like a badass
public story about them making the
decision to walk away we just don't hear
about it and then we get to see the the
results of that success or the failure
more often failure
so a couple things one is i would not
assume clubhouse is down for the count
at all they're young they have plenty of
money they're run by really smart people
i'd give them like a very fighting
chance to figure it out there are a lot
of times when people call twitter down
for the count and they figure it out and
they seem to be doing well right yeah um
so just backing up like and not knowing
anything about their internals like
there's a strong chance they will figure
it out and that people are just down
because they like being down about
companies they like assuming that
they're gonna fail so who knows right
but let's take the ones in the past
where like we know how it played out
there are plenty of examples where
people have turned down big offers and
then you've just never heard from them
again but we never focus on the
companies because you just forget that
those were big but inside your psyche
i think they're um
it's easy for someone with enough money
to say money doesn't matter which i
think is like it's [ __ ] of course
money matters to people
um
but at the moment you just can't even
grasp like the number of zeros that
you're talking about it just doesn't
make sense
right
so to think rationally in that moment is
not something many people are equipped
to do
you